okay so I barbecue at my teeth and I
wanted to see a little bit about me so I
was more or less from New Jersey i was
born in Philadelphia lived in New Jersey
and outside Philadelphia there we go I
wonder if Kristin where I went in is a
physics major I had always loved math
and physics I ended up coming out was
with an engineering physics degree in
the mechanical and aerospace engineering
department which was awesome for what
I'm doing now and also for a lot of the
research I did before I came back to MIT
and then I came up to Boston to get my
PhD in physics at MIT very highly
esoteric subject that was great fun
involving quantum mechanics but not
terribly useful and then I worked for a
couple small companies in the area
mostly doing applications of particle
accelerators to medicine and actually a
lot of it I know you're spending the day
on sort of imaging and image processing
I did a lot with positron emission
tomography images magnetic MRI images
things like that and then in 2002 I came
back to MIT to teach the undergraduate
measurement and instrumentation class
where I basically teach students how to
do experiments and we have a project we
call go forth and measure where each
student picks their own project and does
something actually Kristen what was your
go forth and measure what was your go
forth and measure project we you oh and
you would like to run here track awesome
me too I did I show the pressure sensor
and put it inside a senior and I tried
running on different surfaces and
impact of running on a treadmill versus
running on concrete and we have a lot of
really cool projects like that where
people do everyday things that they're
interested in including food things like
that so anyways back to the women's
technology program so I came to MIT in
2002 in 2006 I was asked to expand the
existing women's technology program
which was founded in 2002 in electrical
engineering and computer science so most
of what you're doing today would fit
more in that and then we expanded it to
mechanical engineering and the goal is
to spark high school girls interest in
studying engineering and computer
science which is I think exactly the
goal of this program too so our approach
is to pick girls to pick students who
are rising high school seniors who are
really good and really interested in
math and science but don't really have a
background in engineering have maybe
heard of engineering people maybe tell
them you should think about engineering
but they don't really know what it is
they haven't taken a lot of engineering
classes they're just curious and not
sure what they want to major in so we
give them a four-week exposure to
engineering there are two curriculum
tracks electrical engineering and
computer science and then the one that I
run which is mechanical engineering I
don't have a lot of time so I can't go
into too much detail but I'll be happy
to answer questions about what we do in
them they're mostly hands-on classes
like what you're doing today we of
course especially a mechanical
engineering have to teach them a lot of
physics because you can't do much in
mechanical engineering until you have
physics but physics is fun it really is
and then we try to correct ideas about
what engineers are like and what they do
and the students give us wonderful quote
such as that they realize engineering
has so much more depth than so many more
applications coming in they have some of
the preconceptions that you might have
which is the engineers work alone you
know it's not very exciting not very
people oriented but in fact it is you
work a lot in teams as I think you're
doing today and you get to do a whole
range of applications and make products
that are helpful to people we also want
to increase confidence of the students
by exposing them to female engineers of
all ages give them an opportunity to
live away from home so it's four weeks
living away from home you live in the
the students live in the MIT dorms they
live with MIT undergrads or recent
graduates who helped them with their
homework and also do social outings and
everything and the classes are taught by
graduate students in mechanical
engineering or ecs and hope I already
said some of this so again it's a
hands-on there's forty students in the
ecs track and twenty students in the
mechanical engineering track so there's
sixty students total we have hands-on
lab classes with projects in mechanical
engineering we like to have a sort of
capstone project at the end of each week
which ranges from building cranes that
can sustain a certain amount of weight
through doing oral presentations making
a poster presentation and then there are
two special final week presentations
where the EECS students build DC motors
and the W tme students build Rube
Goldberg machines which are basically
just chain reaction machines but the
thing we do to make it possibly a little
more interesting is they have to figure
out what's going on in every step so
it's not just trial and error they have
to apply the design principles we've
taught them they have to use the physics
and the science we've taught them to
figure out what's going on and then make
their machine run and we also do a lot
of faculty and Industry guest speakers
and tours we also have as I said MIT
students and recent graduates are the
instructors and also the tutors that
live with the students and these are
some photos from the motor building for
the EECS so this is actually the
professor who runs it they figure out
the design of their motor then they do
all the machining they build them in
pairs so that's one of the completed
motors and they use actually the
mechanical engineering shop to do all
this and then here's some photographs
from the emmy track where you see a Rube
Goldberg machine dominoes or of course
often used various types of trip wires
and things usually pendulums and slinkys
used and then there's a final step they
can decide this one for their final step
they pulled aside a curtain that then
showed a photograph of all the students
and staff so since 2002 reminder again
Emmy started in 2006 but EECS start in
2002 up through last summer we've had
744 females finish the program they all
have a they say wtp has a big impact on
them many of them as also
on the next slide many of them go into
engineering some of them after going
through wtp decided that they actually
don't like engineering it's not for them
that's a perfectly great outcome for us
as well because then they have learned
and save their parents money of sending
them to an engineering school they've
learned oh I don't really like
engineering I want to do something else
so either outcome is fine we just want
to expose them and give them a real more
realistic view of what engineering
actually is many of them would not have
thought of an engineering major or
applying to MIT and as you see actually
many of them end up a plot majoring in
either engineering our computer science
more than sixty percent of the alumni
have major door are majoring in
engineering our computer science many
others in science math a big bunch in
business and then a few of others so
it's highly successful for its goal
which really is to get girls interested
in majoring in engineering or at the
very least to let them know what
engineering is about and this is a I
think the class of 2014 probably and
that's our website and so if you have
any question acknowledgments first I I
couldn't do this alone there's a woman
who runs the ecs program and the whole
program the emmy program is funded by an
amazing woman who's in her actually i
think she just turned 80 who is a
mechanical engineer and she funds our
program and then various other people so
any questions nothing ok ok and if you
are not I know there are some juniors
here which unfortunately you've missed
the deadline for this summer but if you
are not a junior if you're 8 9th or 10th
grader looking around November of your
junior year on that website right there
and look for our application information
and the applications are usually do at
the beginning of January ok ok
Oh